[Music]
[Music]
hi I'm Dan Hayes and welcome to wisdom
for life where we sit through philosophy
to find practical advice that you can
use in your everyday life I'm joined
with my co-host dr. Greg seller and
today we are talking about the Stockdale
paradox named after Admiral James
Stockdale but it might not really be a
paradox after all when we start looking
into it so you you've heard about the
Stockdale paradox before right yeah this
the idea of you know having faith that
you'd come through in a situation but
being very honest about the reality of
the situation I had to look it up I
about a month ago I had a reporter who
contacted me from the Deseret News who
wanted to do a story specifically on the
Stockdale paradox and stoicism and how
that would help us to deal with the cove
in 19 epidemic and quarantines and all
the anxieties it was provoking and so I
you know I knew about Stockdale because
I'd read him when I was an undergraduate
and I taught him early on in my graduate
career and then when I was first
teaching in prisons he was a big hit
with with prisoners - I should mention
by the way and I never saw is that well
you know cuz he was a prisoner of war
and I'll say as well that that's
stoicism as a topic tends to be pretty
popular among prisoners so when you're
teaching philosophy classes they'll
always ask you about that but you know I
knew about Stockdale and it seemed kind
of common sensical to me what he was
saying but I - a lot of people it does
appear paradoxical so I had to go in and
take a look at you know what the actual
Stockdale paradox was and where it came
from and it didn't come directly from
Stockdale came from an interpretation of
stock tales ideas in some management
literature that we can I think we will
talk about in a little bit and so you
know as I was thinking about it
this is one of the things we'll talk
about in the show I was thinking well
why is this a paradox to people what is
so counterintuitive or as we sometimes
say mind-blowing about what Stockdale
was saying to people I think part of it
is that there's been a large movement
towards positive thinking I'm the United
States over the past one you know 40
years I think it's a power the book the
power of positive thinking and through
you know history it's you know going
back to ancient philosophy and also you
know modern research on the topic that
that does not actually give you good
outcomes as well as it could actually
potentially be harmful yeah and and we
can also talk about the positive
psychology movement which has a lot of
good aspects to it a lot of things we
could be positive about I think but
there's there's other parts of it that
I've always found a bit off-putting
you know this emphasis in in you know
sellings positive psychology stuff about
or Seligmann rather about you know
wanting to have a preponderance of
positive over negative emotions it was
always a little bit dubious about first
how you actually count them you know he
has people do a lot of self inventory
which is not a bad thing that's always
good to be paying attention to yourself
and seeing what's really going on inside
of your your head and the reactions that
you're having but you know there was
this kind of you know story that it's
it's just better to be optimistic it's
better to be positive it's better to be
always on you know to be social in that
way and not to bring people down and not
to bring yourself down when negative
emotions might actually have some sort
of value for us or might not be as
negative as people define them as and
there's definitely like a difference
between being like intentionally
negative or like even the negativity yes
when they're depressed yeah where people
who are like chronic
negative because they like getting rises
a lot of people mm-hmm but if you you're
looking at things as the actual like
rational things that could happen that
you know will happen to all of us you
think that these things won't happen to
each other then we're going to set
ourselves up for that failure that that
disconnect between what we think reality
will be like and the actual reality that
we live in yeah you know I'll level with
you and then you can tell me whether
this is the case for you as well I I've
gotten a lot of grief over the years
from people who would say how you're
being too negative and I looked at it as
being realistic as saying hey this is
something that could happen here we
should plan for this or you know you're
saying that this person is got the cure
for whatever ails us that seems a little
overly optimistic to me and that did not
seem to be it might have been the way
that I said it and in some cases a
little bit too emphatically or other
other ways of you know doing things that
that were not well-received for good
reasons but the message by itself often
didn't seem to be something that people
were receptive to and I've gotten better
at that kind of sugarcoating bad news
about what we should but what we should
assume is going to be the case as I've
gotten older I'm wondering have you run
into that yourself
in the course of like you know your
career your relationships when you're in
school where were you the eternal
optimist or where you viewed as the
pessimist or somewhere in between I
guess part of being on doing like
science and engineering and computer
science is that you're constantly
looking at like edge cases yeah and so
you have to be aware of all the pitfalls
that are it's its inherent otherwise you
have very bad outcomes and so on part of
like just my training and my career is
looking at all the things that can
go wrong because those every teen needs
to be crossed in every ID that needs to
be dotted as well as you know just in
like common conversation of you know
being careful about I guess giving an
advice when people don't want it and you
know there's something that I see with a
lot of people is that they hold their
ideas as something that is almost
equivalent to them and so if you yes say
something that is right yeah and so if
you say something that goes against the
ideas that they hold to be true then
they feel like they are attack you that
you are attacking them and and so
sometimes it requires a little bit of
you know verbal jujitsu to actually
present the idea without them thinking
that you're attacking them yeah I mean
ideally the Blaise Pascal points this
out in his Ponce's if you're really good
at that you get them to have that as
their own idea essentially taking credit
for what you're putting on the table
which is fine because you're not
interested in the credit you're
interested in them taking seriously the
warning that you're you're trying to
give them about something that that
could go wrong and harm them or harm
their interests or damage them in in
some other way so yeah so let's talk
about Stockdale himself not everybody
was gonna necessarily be familiar with
him and some people might be familiar
with him from his ill-fated
vice-presidential run as Ross Perot's
candidate his running mate yeah and and
and that he did not come across too well
there was a debate between him and was a
Dan Quayle and and Al Gore the vice
presidential candidates and it's one of
the where we actually had three
presenters up on stage because the
Reform Party had an
of a backing at that time to merit being
on stage I mean I again I'll level with
you I think third parties should be on
stage all the time I think we'd have
much better debates about policy if we
let the greens and libertarians and the
Constitution party and whoever else can
muster up enough votes to be involved in
it but he got up there and he just got
like pummeled and people came to get
I'll go ahead and pummeled by Dan Quayle
as quite a fees well yeah he coming off
2% of the people actually said that he
won the debate
and you gotta said Wow well those must
have been really committed people or I
don't I don't know what they were
watching but everybody else said that
Wow this this makes it hard to take Ross
Perot seriously that he picked this guy
and it's unfortunate because when you
read Stockdale he was actually quite a
brilliant guy and he understood that as
you know Clausewitz the great military
historian had put it taking this from
napoleon that the moral or the we can
call it the ethical or organizational
stuff in in military tactics and
strategy was way more important than
just material or typical battlefield
tactics or anything like that and he
carried that forward with him
when he became a prisoner of war during
the Vietnam conflict and he you know I
was rereading this earlier today he was
one of the top guys so he knew when his
plane got shot down and he was
parachuting that if he survived once he
got into the prison camp he would be the
top ranking officer in the prison camp
and therefore responsible for all of the
other American
well Airmen right under his command and
and the officers so he wound up being a
prisoner of war and you know it's quite
understandable that the Vietnamese were
not happy about
pilots in particular given the bombings
that were going on and and the you know
the fact that they've been fighting the
French first and then we're fighting us
he was stuck in the prison camps for
years and years and years and he talked
to over five years yeah I mean just
imagine that you know World War two
lasted less than that for us you know he
was stuck I mean now we're in the time
of forever wars we've we've been in
Afghanistan for an entire generation and
and Iraq for almost an entire generation
but that was pretty unheard of at that
time and so he had to find a way to
adapt it he credits it to Epictetus and
having studied both the enchiridion and
the discourses of Epictetus and having
all of those things as he says ready at
hand when he parachuted down and he also
says too that he never told any of the
people that whether his captors were his
fellow American captives that he was
relying on stoic philosophy to get
through but he says that that was
essential to being able to manage his
prison camp experience might be
interesting that wonder ask him why he
didn't share this have you felt there
was such a boon for him getting through
his own ordeal that's actually a really
good question
and I would suspect that it has to do
with not letting people in on the secret
of your success right you if and if it's
going to work for the people that you're
allies with the people that your
comrades with they don't necessarily
need to know what book it's coming from
while you're in the middle of the prison
camp it would be just fine to say well
here are some principles let's put these
into practice and you definitely
wouldn't want your captors to know that
if they can go and check out epictetus
they might be able to figure out where
your thought process is coming right
that would be a bad idea
so I suspect that's probably part of it
but Epictetus also himself tells tells
us don't call yourself a philosopher
don't call yourself a stoic because odds
are you're actually going to embarrass
yourself by by not doing a very good job
with it so maybe that's part of it as
well potentially yeah I know I just you
know there's always a very pro-social on
aspect to oh yeah a lot of the writings
within Sohus ISM and so I finally
especially because he is a commander of
men that if he wasn't sharing these
things it seems like that would be I
know that he's not working with them as
well as he could well you know
accordingly his accounts their their
communication is very limited there
they're often having to communicate in
clandestine ways you know through codes
and tapping and you know leaving notes
in different places so I imagine that
was probably part of it but yeah there's
there's probably more to be explored
there and you know the other thing that
you can say is that in a way Stockdale
he he illustrates one side of stoicism I
I don't think that that in in the
writings that I've seen from him
I don't see an awful lot of that
pro-social as we're calling it aspect
where you're supposed to be thinking
about you know the community as a whole
and really focusing on justice it's more
stoicism as a way of surviving the
camp's he talks about you know when he
parachutes down he's he's coming into
this domain in which you know ancient
philosophy could could actually be like
the norm because he's he's not going
back into the Stone Age but he's
certainly going out of the modern
technological we can take a break from
things sort of sort of environment right
and there's all kind of piggy bets on
our
topic for last week which was resilience
yeah you know we are far more capable of
dealing with difficult things and we
think and and part of this is is the
mindset of you know having that goal
that final that faith that wish that's
something that you'll get through it but
you know knowing that this is gonna be
hard and you gotta like just dig in yeah
you know another thing that he did talk
about as well that I was struck by it
and rereading this is that most of them
broke under torture and he said that one
of the things that they really had to
deal with was a sense of guilt that they
would be brought back into the the camp
and some of their fellow Americans would
want to talk to them and they would say
don't talk to me I'm a traitor you know
you can't essentially like I'm
disgusting don't look at me and you know
bringing up that resilience thing I
think one of the aspects of resilience
is being able to pick ourselves up after
we screwed up and failed to whatever
degree sometimes it's like catastrophic
complete failure you know like watch
everything fall down sometimes it's like
failures that other people don't
actually note but we know that we failed
and being able to hold ourselves
accountable without imposing all sorts
of extra guilt or shame or whatever we
want to call it upon ourselves I think
that's part of resiliency what do you
think absolutely the two you know the
one idea is to bend but not break to be
able to you know go with the flow and
and not fail but you know we all will
fail at some point in time at the very
end we're going to die
there's you know a final failure at
least at some point on and it's not
something that we need to I think worry
about too much if it's part of life
and and everyone does it then it can't
be all bad yeah that's true and and you
know Epictetus reminds us and I don't
remember exactly where the discourse is
I think it's in book 4 but he talks
about Socrates success rate and Socrates
is a hero right so he if anybody's
getting things right it ought to be him
and he says Socrates managed to reach
about one in a thousand and convinced
them that they should change their life
and focus more on their soul and less on
their body and external possessions and
try to cultivate virtue so you know hey
if Socrates is batting you know what
would would that be point zero zero one
no I'm getting or I'm gonna be like
Socrates is banning Oh point one point
two zero one maybe it's not so bad if
we're not successful all the time you
know but I mean there's kind of a
narrative out there that presents it as
if we need to be if not successful all
the time if we do fail we have to like
find some way to spin some gold out of
that straw you know we've got it we've
got to pick ourselves up and learn from
the failure and then you know do an
after-action report and I think you know
sometimes that can be helpful but a lot
of times that just places undue stress
on people there there are times when
we're just not going to be creative or
particularly on point
my daughter was talking to me today
about needing to do some painting
projects and just not feeling like it
and I said well that's fine you know you
paint when you can actually paint if
you're trying to force it you'll get
some results but not results that you're
really happy with sometimes you just
have to without you know being sort of
lackadaisical about it you have to let
yourself fit into the the groove that
you can but we're getting kind of far
away from Stockdale yeah let's come back
to to talking about the so the paradox
what is the paradox itself
what's paradoxical about what this guy
has to say he's in a prison camp he
survives
he sees lots of other people who don't
survive and that's where I think the
paradox is coming from right yeah I
think we look at this there's a
conversation between Stockdale and Jim
Collins that kind of comes at this point
and so conversation is you know Collins
says who doesn't make it out and stock
Doris Pine responds oh that's easy
the optimists the optimist says Jim I
don't understand how you was I'm
completely confused well given what he'd
said a hundred meter earlier yes the
optimist says Stockdale oh they were the
ones who said we're going to be out by
Christmas and Christmas would come and
Christmas would go and then they'd say
we're going to be out by Easter and
Easter would come and Easter would go
and then Thanksgiving and then it would
be Christmas again and they died of a
broken heart
ya know what do you think he means by a
broken heart in that case I guess he
they have set up for themselves in their
minds eye on these illusions I guess you
know optimistic thoughts of oh we're
going to get saved and every time that
they say Oh we'll be saved by Christmas
or Oh we'll be saved by Easter or over
will be saved by Thanksgiving on it is a
massive blow to I guess their ego or to
their on their thinking because they
haven't already prepared for the the
opposite possibility it's a really good
possibility that they're not going to
get saved at this point in time and this
can go on and on and if you never think
about well what are the alternatives and
you convince yourself that something
will happen and then it doesn't happen
that that's a big you know blow to your
your psyche your ego yeah if you want to
say that yeah you know I wonder - so
weak we can sometimes say well
everything's gonna turn out okay I've
got faith that this is going to be great
you know this will happen at this time
this will happen at this time that's one
way of being
unduly optimistic maybe there's another
way to in saying well at least this
isn't happening you know this this over
here is bad but at least it's not even
worse than it is and you know I wonder
if there isn't there's there's some
positive utility in doing that right in
reminding yourself that I may be in
solitary confinement which is one of the
things they did to these guys in the
prison camp quite quite a lot but at
least I'm not being tortured at this
moment in time all right that might be a
very helpful thing to do
well that reframing yeah but I think
that a lot of people will will at times
get themselves tangled up by maybe
picking the wrong and if we're talking
about reframing maybe they reframe it in
the wrong ways you know because we could
apply this not just to like being in a
prison camp or any other similar
situation like being stuck under your
car after a terrible accident or
something like that but we could apply
it to being in a bad relationship or
being stuck at a job that you hate but
you don't see a way out of because you
know there's there's not a lot of other
jobs out there and and I think people do
this a lot there's quite a few people
who are like man if I can just hang on
till the way I've seen it with educators
if I can just hang on til the end of the
semester everything's gonna be great
after that and then things aren't you
know or if I can just put in another
year with this person I'm sure they're
gonna like turn around and finally love
me you know or or pick pick any any sort
of thing along those lines my boss will
finally recognize me you know and I'll
get promoted like I deserve you can also
say well at least I'm not being fired
and there is something to that but in a
way it's kind of like putting the bar
lower and lower than then it ought to be
and maybe that's a maladaptive kind of
it's not optimism as such but it's sort
of a consoling oneself I would say it's
there's a difference in how much agency
someone has and so for someone the
area of Stockdale use has very little
agency as a prisoner and the more agency
you have the more decisions you are
given to actually deal with and and so
we like talking about the the person
that's either the teacher saying that
job that they might hate or you know
someone is saying in a relationship that
is just not beneficial for them they
still have lots of agency in those
situations and they it would behoove
them probably you know to have a better
life if they me made some changes that
are there but first you have to be aware
of the the situation at hand you have to
call things what they really are right
then so that's part of the Stockdale
paradox so part of part of the paradox
is and I guess this is why people think
it's paradoxical is that you're looking
at things in two ways at the same time
you're you're not being an optimist
because you're being brutally realistic
about the situation that you're in and
and the future prospects of it right if
it's a prison camp you don't know if
you're ever gonna be rescued you might
die before you rescued you might you
might break and be a psychological wreck
or who knows your your body in stock
Dale's case that he broke his leg coming
down and they really as well and you
know you read about this stuff and it's
you you wince reading about it so
there's that side of it well let's call
that aspect a and then there's aspect B
which seems to be optimistic but it's
not optimistic in the same sense as like
the everything's going to be okay
things are gonna work Stockdale talks
about faith that you would come through
the situation in in some way but that's
a bit different than I'm going to be
rescued by Christmas or I'm going to be
rescued by by April or they're gonna
quit being mean to me and and I think
that what part of what Stockdale is is
implicitly relying on you
something that we can find in stoic
philosophy and in other traditions of
virtue ethics this notion that we have
resources within ourselves that we can
draw upon and need to cultivate even
though we're not in the best situation
for cultivating them that then will
allow us to make it through so there's
you you mentioned agency part of what's
going on with stoic philosophy is the
recognition that agency lies within
even when seemingly all the external
agency has been cut off we can still
determine our own attitude towards
things and not only can we we should
we're responsible for that so we have
two sides there side B is is something
that seems optimistic and Stockdale does
use word faith we might also use the
word hope I think but these have to be
kept in mind at the same time you can't
have a single-minded optimism or else
you're going to you're gonna founder
things are not gonna work out for you by
a doing positive thinking and and what
you were talking about is positive
thinking in a lot of cases excludes the
looking at aspects that are just are
what they are they get labeled as
negative yeah to look at reality and say
that reality is negative I think is a
miscarriage of the word I mean we can
say things are negative in this way or
in this way like epictetus again are you
talking about him a lot but he you know
makes sense cuz Stockdale
talks about Epictetus a lot Epictetus
does say that you can be hindered for
example in your leg he and Stockdale are
both lame both by injuries to to their
legs and you are in fact limited I have
a similar thing I'm missing two two
ligaments and one knee that I injured at
the beach almost a decade ago and
haven't gotten replacement ligaments for
probably never will so you know I can't
run on that leg and that means I can't
run on either
both right and so that's an impediment
to running but it's not an impediment to
doing leg presses or to walking
carefully or to I don't know doing doing
other things right so we can we can
realistically recognize that there could
be things that are negative you know as
so I bring in picture Frankel who also
oh yeah dealt with being in prison and
he was a psychologist and he was a Jew
that was in prison death camps for the
during World War two yeah yeah and he
wrote a book really a lovely book called
man's search for meaning and he part of
it is his recounting his experiences
within the camps as well as the other
part is his idea of the psychology of
what is going on there which is has a
lot of parallels to what Stockdale has
and he's got a couple quotes those who
have a wide to live can bear with almost
any how and life is never made
unbearable by circumstances but only by
the lack of meaning and purpose and so
this is kind of that idea of that like
wish or hope or faith that you know the
end result will be good and you don't
put it in like any temporal terms yeah
and and maybe one of the aspects has to
be on determining what really is good I
mean if if good means getting to eat as
much candy as you like and your life is
probably not going to turn out okay
whether you're in a prison camp or
anywhere else I mean you know in today's
industrial society if you wanted to pile
up candy around yourself you could do
that and then once you've got diabetes
you maybe have to cut back a bit you
know you and Viktor Frankl talks about a
story of on these really gaunt men going
around and giving away their food
as they had made you know in his words
hid their meaning to be those that are
charitable to go around and to take care
of everyone that they possibly could
yeah I'm and and even though they're
very gaunt they were the ones that
survived so you know it's it's
interesting that he uses the word
meaning there that's that's a very
modern word and I see I see a lot of
people in when they're looking at virtue
ethics or they're looking at philosophy
as a way of life they talk a lot about
meaning finding meaning in this finding
a meaning of this
it's not something that we see a lot in
ancient philosophy I don't think it's as
if the the concept didn't exist but we
don't have words for that sort of thing
we do have purpose
alright and they like what we're doing
things for and I wonder if if that do
you think that's important that there's
like a newer way of articulating it that
kind of catches I think it's it's
actually a positive step that we
identify something as meaning and we say
that that's that's part of what makes a
life a valuable life a good life even if
we're in terrible circumstances right
absolutely especially the like there's a
purpose and but like meaning is like a
purpose of life is it not to a certain
extent yeah although sometimes we talk
about finding meaning and it doesn't
sound exactly like it's the end purpose
but it's it's in what we're doing like
when people talk about know you're
mentioning service to others when you're
when you're engaged in that sort of
thing it's not the end result it's the
process itself right and we can say
similar things to I think about
relationships as a matter of fact a lot
of relationships go off the rails when
people are to end purpose centered on
things you know I want to I want to you
know get somebody to wash my clothes and
you know have sex with and help with the
finances and things ok those those are
all good parts of the relationship but
that can't be all that's going on there
if it's going to be a good romantic
relationship involved with you know
cohabiting the process not the end yeah
the destination I want to say that both
of the matter though that we do we have
to have people who say it's the journey
not the destination or or have that
trope it's really the friends we met
along the way
you know I think that's important but
that's that can't be the totality either
you know and again we're very far away
from from in talking about this I think
from the prison camps that Chronicle and
Stockdale we're in but I think it could
well useful the end and to also like
maybe bring in the existentialist just a
little bit because they are a lot of
them we're talking about creating your
own meaning that there oh yeah very good
yeah yeah I'm actual meaning out there
for you to find that is always up to you
is very something you can roll in here
because you yeah now have a why you are
creating the meaning the goal that you
are setting for yourself in here that
it's not out there to be grabbed or
grasp it's interesting the atheistic
existentialists
among whom we could include and granted
some of these people rejected the title
of existentialist but you know if we're
talking very broadly we can talk about
say Martin Heidegger and jean-paul
Sartre and Albert Camus all of them were
kind of down on hope and they thought
that maybe you know you actually ought
to engage with the despair that that
that life brings which means that your
reliance the way start put it you're
reliant on your own resources everything
that you do could like founder if it
involves somebody else they could like
not show up to do what they're supposed
to do but that's it you're stuck with it
and then Camus you know he at least in
the myth of sisyphus a little bit less
so in his later writings he he's he's
down on hope because he thinks that hope
leads to
to optimistic of a viewpoint on things
but Gabrielle Marcel who was by the way
the first person used the word
existentialism in French he talks about
hope is being very important and and he
doesn't think that the world is absurd
the way that say Camus or Sartre think
it is he actually talks about the world
as being mysterious rather meaning that
there's there's something to be revealed
that we can't get at with sort of
technologically oriented ways of
problem-solving but we have to you know
grasp what he calls some the ontological
depths of things but he he talks about
hope and he's got a really nice
characterization of it early on in his
works where he says hope consists in
asserting that there is at the heart of
being beyond all data or things that we
can observe beyond all inventories and
all calculations a mysterious principle
which is in connivance with me meaning
that there's something within the order
of things that's gonna work with me I
don't know what it is and it may not and
he he follows up and says it may not
actually give me what I want because it
you know I have to actually want the
right things so if you know getting out
of the camp by Christmas is what I want
that doesn't mean that you know the
cosmos or the universe is going to
cooperate with me and open up the doors
because maybe the cosmos doesn't care
about that or maybe that's not the best
thing for me but but the things that are
genuinely and I think the Stoics are
kind of you know again they've you
things that in a way like this - if what
we desire is the right thing for us the
desire having this this sense that
things will cooperate with us to some
degree things that are that are outside
of our control that can help to see us
through and it may turn out that nothing
does cooperate with us but we can we can
at least try something you know and
somebody else who who this reminds me I
was William James I don't know have you
ever read the the will to believe and
it's a really interesting short essay
I have not though the famous line from
it has to do with the fact that the
robbers of the train is back in train
robbery days right they there's like
four or five of them they get on the
train and they can all expect that their
comrades are gonna follow their leads
right whereas all the other people in
the the train they don't say 60 of them
they could easily rise up and attack
these train robbers but there's no
coordination between them right and part
of the reason is because they don't have
any hope of being able to overcome them
individually and James he talks about
how there are some things that we could
believe in and legitimately believe in
but we can't really grasp them as we're
we can't verify them let's say unless we
originally trust and make a move so you
think about going out on a date right
you you want to date somebody you looked
at their profile on social media you
think that you're compatible maybe used
an app to connect with them you're like
let's go and have dinner together let's
see what see where this goes right now
if you get there and you demand proofs
of their affection at every moment
you're never gonna get anywhere right
you have to like try some stuff out you
have to you have to put yourself out
there and take a risk and if you if you
wait until you know you've got like in
incontrovertible evidence that this is
gonna be the right person for you
because the algorithm said so or
something like that I mean even even
trusting in the algorithm as trusting in
something you don't you don't understand
right
if you don't launch yourself into that
you won't get the confirming experience
then know that that allows you to have
that belief and I think that also it's a
leap of faith there it's I know it's
kind of a leap of faith but but kind of
not because it's not launching into
something you have no idea about
and there could be lessening the waters
maybe as there could be increments to it
right like you try something small out
first then you get a little bit more
confident that a little bit more
confidence and there could be like a
feedback loop almost this but James was
stressing that there's there's there's a
lot of things in our life that we
absolutely have to do this way you know
there's there's no way we're gonna be
able to like calculate everything before
we do it yeah this you bring the
existentialists and and James as well
Kunal seems to roll into this remind me
of Simone de Beaulieu bard and her book
the ethics of ambiguity yes and and her
her final conclusion that like as we go
through our existential crises and
realize that we need to make our own
meaning and kind of like become akin to
maybe what nietzsche would call the over
man or something on that are so the yeah
over man whoever bench that we realize
that we can't actually do all the things
unless we have other people who are also
like us who are also having and creating
their own meaning and living their own
lives for their own sake and and that's
kind of like a pro-social outcome of
hope that we can make ourselves the
world around us better yeah and that is
where her approach like blue Sartre
and Nietzsche out of the water because
you know yeah you're right the the
Nietzschean whatever the ubermensch is
which he's very clear were not oh we
could we can maybe prepare the way for
or you know who knows maybe become
something kind of on the way to it
whatever that is it's it's kind of a
solitary being it may it may have just a
few fellow uber mention to hang out with
but you know he says that it's as far
above the normal human as the human is
over the ape so not a lot of like
engagement with
others and then with Sartre you know
Sark thinks that there really is no
meaning we have to create it the world
is essentially absurd and de Beauvoir
says no the world is not absurd the
world is ambiguous and she you know the
ethics of ambiguity is her attempt to
provide what Sartre her lover and
partner was totally unable to provide an
existentialist ethics and so yeah keep I
don't know if he's unable because maybe
he just saw the ethics of an annuity and
said of like well frakkin you know like
no I didn't know that that's thing that
I can't actually top this I don't know
it's kind of hard to say that he could
not he did not well he struggled but he
tried this and and yeah I mean if we
were talking in sort of like the sense
of bear possibility he could have put
things together in such a way as to
derived a better ethics in point of fact
he didn't and Simone de Beauvoir comes
along and and does provide it you know
but in any so go ahead and we should
probably move on to our question here
yeah so coming back to the Stockdale
paradox right the need that that we we
have to be brutally realistic and avoid
any undue optimism and yet have a kind
of faith that things are gonna turn
alright we have a it's kind of a
challenge rather than a question coming
from a friend and colleague of mine
Chuck Chakrapani he said personally I've
always wondered if Stockdale mistakenly
attributed optimism as the cause of some
soldiers perishing my observation has
been the true optimists ignore it if
their predictions don't be about they're
so optimistic is what he's saying that
they they ignore the evidence that
things aren't working they revise their
predictions to suit their optimism in
October will be out by Christmas and
come January it's will be out by Easter
and so on and he says actually I have a
business partner who does that really
doesn't seem to shake his perpetual
optimism and that psychological studies
so favor optimism is more favorable to
survival
now I stock field does talk about people
moving the benchmarks and but it seems
like Stockdale thinks that you can only
do that so long and then after a while
you you have to admit it if Chuck is
right then there are some people who are
able to be perpetual optimists and
continually tell themselves things that
there's really no good evidence for
actually there's plenty of counter
evidence right and they keep on making
predictions of things they're just gonna
work out and in a William James Ian sort
of way they're very faith that things
are gonna work out helps to produce the
outcome that they want now so what's the
difference or what's the line between
in-stream optimism and being delusional
well that's what I was going to say I
think that at a certain point you know
it said to be optimistic in that way
means to keep on denying important
features of the context or environment
that one is in and one's own resources
as well it's thinking I've always got
what I need to be able to handle this
sort of thing I just have to you know
stay chipper or look at the bright side
of life or whatever it's going to be
right
hi this brings to mind the the I believe
it's a quote attributed to Einstein that
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again and expecting different
outcomes and yeah optimistic and you're
doing the same thing over and over
oh just next time it will happen next
time will happen eventually you need to
look at this and we realize that what
you're doing isn't doing the things that
you want to do but here's the question
that that comes with it can this sustain
a person can this allow them it is we
could say maybe what they're doing is
insane but can we say that they're it's
functional they're able to keep
themselves going until whatever
liberation if there's ever going to be a
liberation
will will occur or I mean maybe maybe we
have to think about like what else are
they losing in the process by being out
of touch with reality is a question that
I think the best answer that could give
is I don't know and the might require
some more research I actually get a
better answer I mean my experience and
and and since you know Chuck is bringing
up just experience I think it's
perfectly fine for each of us to bring
our experiences in my experience has
been that people who are unduly
optimistic and unrealistic about the
circumstances that they're in tend to
make things worse for themselves over
time and tend to create all sorts of
additional burdens for other people that
they're connected with and so I don't I
don't think that they are really
successful in in most cases I mean it's
there was a cartoon character that some
people might be familiar with mr. Magoo
and he was this this really dense guy
who would constantly create chaos around
himself and he was always going along
perfectly financed these big thick
glasses couldn't really see anything and
he would like you know touch like a you
know a snake that's poisonous and think
it's a cane and just use it that way and
you'd be like wow this guy's really
adaptive to his environment yes except
that he creates total chaos around him
and suffering and and you know car
crashes and and all sorts of negative
outcomes for people so I don't think
it's really adaptive in any real sense
it's almost like they're it's a being
privileged you know by reality to be the
one I in the the center of the storm
right and I don't even think that it
that's I mean mr. Magoo is a fictional
character I don't think that that's
really the case for most people I think
most people who are unduly optimistic
there is usually something going on
there that we can pick at and probe and
say why are they so what what's the need
to be so optimistic that they have to
deny the reality that they're facing
I I don't know I think the only thing
that's coming to mind is like though a
TV show dharma & greg which was kind of
that basic idea where Dharma's was kind
of fighting and totally optimistic greg
is a straight man who has to deal with
picking up all the things and and
dealing with this person and every once
in a while they learn a lesson about
each other
right yeah the standard sitcom fare
whatnot but but I see I've had like
relationships with people who are not
resilient and they they do have have
like a you know an optimistic you know
like it's kind of like the secret you
know put it out into the universe and
they'll come back to you or whatnot yeah
and um and I think they're just setting
themselves up for for failures that like
what they're doing isn't actually based
in something solid and concrete and and
you're I guess you're creating a
subjective world that is not quite
mapping on to the real yeah and you know
to go back to the origin of the this
calling this a paradox right Collins was
interested in companies his book is
called good to great and he's looking at
companies that were doing well and then
started doing even better and he
identified the stoic paradox as one of
the characteristics of good to great
companies the Stockdale paradox yeah
yeah and so you know his view about this
was that in a business environment where
you know you do things like limited
resources competition you know all of
those sorts of things change in in the
environment due to innovation or or
other factors you have to be realistic
about your circumstances rather than
just like creating reports that look
look good to the stockholders and to you
know whoever else is looking at the
company you've got to actually face the
challenges that the company has or else
you're going to sooner or later run into
problems reality will hit you in the
nose you might say with
a rolled-up newspaper like you're a bad
dog or something if you don't if you
don't pay attention to it
I suppose you know if we want to use
that metaphor then at least you you know
when to duck if if you're paying
attention to the reality there and so I
that's that's that seems to be my
response to this this challenge that's
posed by Chuck I don't think that
optimists like that can hold on to that
optimism relentlessly forever I I'm in
agreement
I think we should move on to our
practice here yeah so do you want to
lead us through that yeah so uh this
practice here is a more recent practice
it's called woop and it's was developed
by Gabrielle Gabrielle attenion um and
she's a research psychologist and it's
got a couple of things that we've
already talked about like part of this
is negative is realization and the whole
idea here is that it's packaging it
together and so the woop stands for wish
outcome obstacle and plan and so the
idea here is you're trying to find the
best outcomes for your goals that you're
setting for yourself and I thought this
was very useful for thinking about the
Stockdale paradox and we have a a wish
that is going to be our final outcome
and but being very aware of the problems
the obstacles that we were going to be
doing and so wish is you make a big goal
and that hope for wish and then the
outcome is the positive visualization of
how it feels to do and accomplish that
goal and the then you right after that
you had to make sure that you actually
look at the obstacles and you- visualize
to see all the the possible things that
could hinder you in this and you dwell
upon those as well and then you make a
plan and so this is a implementation on
imperative and so it's a if-then
statement so if
and or when some obstacle happens that
you've been thinking about in your
obstacles then I will do some action to
overcome that obstacle and so you want
to think about all the major obstacles
that you're going to be facing and so I
guess in the terms of Stockdale here we
would be talking about on oh they're
gonna come and they're gonna torture me
and I need to you know still my resolve
and think about what is the actual true
good thing here especially we was
talking about Epictetus then he's
thinking that the true good is my
actions and the the pain my body or are
not the true goods and so I can focus on
what is the true good here I'm or you
know being stuck in the hole or you know
just dealing with the boredom and how
how am I going to think about dealing
with those things when those things
actually happen I already have a plan to
do those things and one you can actually
go please well I was gonna ask you so is
this something that then would be
iterated where you know we say you know
oftentimes you know wash cycle repeat
right so you you go through this entire
process of having the goal figuring out
what it what it is that you actually
want you know some Values Clarification
thinking about the outcome that you're
aiming at thinking about the obstacles
that are in the way and then coming up
with the plan and that gets you to this
stage but there's probably going to be
new obstacles that arise coming out of
the action that you do or maybe doing
the action itself raises what wait a
second I'm going to need this in order
to be able to do the action right or I
need to get other people to be involved
in this I can't do this all by myself
how will I persuade others so does it
sort of branch off into multiple uses of
this this same thing yeah absolutely and
you can use it for like your wish can be
a big goal or it could just be a small
goal like hey want to change a habit you
know simple like I want to go running
every morning or I just you know I want
to come home and not turn on the TV or
something yeah you know little things
but you can also use it for big things
so you can
break up those big things into smaller
things you could hack you could say like
I'm going to do a whoop and part of the
on the visualization how you're going to
accomplish the goal will be more whoops
so you know I mean when you're talking
about this this this seems like
something I would want to do because it
feels like something I have been doing
right yeah something that people who are
doing successful decision-making or
problem solving or whatever whatever
else we're going to be concerned with
immoral life have to do if they're going
to be it's not the only way to do it but
but this is one way to be successful at
it so is this something that we could
we'd need to do in an explicit way or is
it okay to do it in kind of an intuitive
or implicit way what do you think then
kind of fit by mocking it explicit I
think so just because there's a lot of
people that will not do the negative
visualization point I think that's
that's probably oh yeah is everyone oh
yeah I'm gonna get an a on my tester I'm
gonna get the job or I'm gonna you know
but you don't think about like okay well
then what happens when I need to I deal
with the consequences of not getting
those things so that means those are
gonna it's sort of like in cards against
humanity' I don't know if you've never
played that oh yeah okay
so there's there's there's a card that
has do something that's like step a and
then step B is a big question mark and
then stop CEA's profit right right now
it looks great on paper but what's that
what's that middle part that that how
are you gonna get the profit that's
that's the the key where everything
comes together so you're saying that if
you don't actually figure out what the
obstacle is it may as well be like that
card from cards against humanity' right
and one of the things I found out
recently was really interesting that
they did a study on basketball players
and they had two groups of varying skill
levels and they had one group practice
doing basketball hoops and the other
group just thought about doing
basketball hoops
and for those people who had at least
some skill in basketball both groups on
increase their ability to do hoops
because the brain is very easily tricked
that imagining things are running the
same pathways as the actual doing of
those things yeah well that's that's a
great thought to sort of finish up on
we're getting close to the end of our
hour do you have any last ideas thoughts
things that you want to say about this
topic
[Music]
if you get on a hole and you can't get
out
maybe the Stockdale paradox is for you
okay that's that's fitting it to end on
so we'd like to thank you for listening
thank you goodbye
[Music]
[Music]